hello um i'd just like to thank
lab roots for the opportunity to speak
my name is bridget algae hewitt i'm a
senior research scientist at stanford
university in the center for comparative
studies in race
and ethnicity i'm a biological
anthropologist by training with
specialization in forensic anthropology
and my area of focus is in computational
methods
or improving human identification
specifically along the
u.s mexico border and that's what i will
be speaking about today
my talk forensic anthropology at the
line
or the colloquial term for the border
advances in computational methods for
the identification of the u.s
mexico border dead
the recovery laboratory analysis and
return of human remains
of unknown identity is important in
humanitarian context
and i would argue one if not the most
pressing areas of need
and challenging areas of research for
forensic anthropology today
is the u.s mexico border
violence unrest poverty and persecution
have forced thousands of latin american
migrants from their home countries
to attempt the perilous journey el norte
through the deserts the jungles
the urban spaces of central america and
mexico
some perish from dehydration exhaustion
and injury
others crumble under the weight of
deterrence policies that shape the
landscape of the u.s mexico borderlands
in the last 20 years alone over 7 500
migrants have been found deceased
after attempting to cross the u.s mexico
border
over 5 500 migrants have been reported
disappeared
countless more missing and deceased and
many remains will never be found
enforcement-only policies like operation
gatekeeper already 25 years old or the
present-day
migrant protection protocols which many
of us know as the remain in mexico
policy
represent strategies of control through
deterrence these acts of control
are successful but successful at
increasing risk of death
the control policies also work to
humanize dehumanize migrants
and as deterrent actions they not only
increase the risk of death
but also the magnitude of actual death
counts
the resulting counts then are a reminder
of the humanitarian
crisis and the human consequences
of the militarization of the borderlands
and the criminalization of the
undocumented
just as the undocumented or forced by
structural institutional and physical
violence into the shadowed margins of
society
in life they are left to remain faceless
nameless and disappeared even in death
so as a reminder then in the last 20
years alone
7 500 migrants have been found deceased
when attempting to cross the border 5500
or more
have been reported disappeared countless
more missing and deceased
and many remains will never be found
perspectives can be i think better
grasped by a
more focused approach to the analysis
so we're going to look at today
estimates from pima county in arizona
and that encompasses the tucson area
conservative estimates from pima county
alone suggests that
over 3 000 migrants died while
attempting to cross the border
since 2000 1200
or so remain unidentified and the
pima county office of the medical
examiner is one of the
largest forensic anthropology
case analysis centers for the border
so one of the problems with the border
identification
is the changing trends in death and
identification success
and in a period when border crossing
counts were
or are historically low at the end of
the obama presidency they had actually
reached
an unprecedented level of
reduction migrants are now perishing
at ever-increasing numbers at the same
time
the ability of the forensic
anthropologists to positively identify
the migrant dead
is declining at an unprecedented rate
yet we're finding that our casework
protocols are
not changing
pima county office of the medical
examiner has reported
a decrease in positive identification
rates of migrant deaths
from 75 in 2003
to 45 in 2013. it's remarkable to see
such a change
in only a decade and it should give us
as scientists
and advocates and practitioners
great pause and motivation
for improving identification rates and
actually getting at the source of this
issue so in the throes of this crisis
immediate improvement to forensic
identification is critical
as we have to attempt to speak the story
of the dead
as our role as forensic anthropologists
give closure to the family and friends
of the missing
and uphold our values of social justice
and commitment to human rights
improvement i would argue though cannot
be achieved by the traditional methods
of forensic anthropology alone
these are the methods that have brought
about that reduction in
positive identification rates and we are
faced with a new border culture
a new border environment given different
policies
and different peoples crossing the
border so these new conditions
demand equally new and especially
holistic
approaches to casework id that take all
of
not only the individual but the context
and the social conditions into account
and this is i think most important
um in light of the fact that migrants do
not just disappear
they are disappeared so taking into
account that
holism of the migrant the missing
migrant issue
is critical because there are several
scientific
and societal factors that actively
impede the successful recovery
identification and repatriation of
missing migrants along the border and
there's numerous
they depend on the methods that we use
the reference collections that are used
to facilitate these methods
the problem of dna degradation because
we're working in the
desert so that's going to be a issue of
dna preservation post-mortem interval
will also in the desert rapidly
decompose remains which changes your
opportunity for making identifications
using particular methods
the recovery context is critical and i'm
going to talk about that later where the
location along the border
makes a difference in our ability to
actually infer information about the
individual
preservation again dna and
soft tissue preservation etc is all
going to be affected by
environment it's essential to note
that while profiles may be uploaded to
codis
border crossers are very rarely
criminals
and they're very rarely than in criminal
databases
they are mothers fathers sisters
brothers families coming with
children they're not going to be
identified then
by using the traditional forensic means
that said then we have poor comparative
databases we don't have a
comprehensive migrant database for
families to report
they're missing and include their dna in
or for
forensic anthropologists to include the
dna from those who have not yet been
identified we have shifting debt migrant
demographics
which means that methods and protocols
that were established under the
assumption
that all migrants come from northern
mexico
that may have been true at one point in
time
are radically outdated by the shifts
in the demographic makeup of who's
actually migrating now
and crossing and dying on the border
there's also issues of infrastructure
who is going to support
this kind of work the funding to pay for
the dna testing
the political policies that may
prohibit certain types of um
activities or inhibit those um
policies whether or not those are
political in terms of presidential
policies but they can be
policies of people working within
universities areas where
time is considered to be best well spent
there's also public opinions on methods
of identification
and what is a value
that can get transmitted to um
in the course of the expert giving their
um opinion and then it actually ending
up uh reported to someone else
and interpreted and then it may impede
an identification that brings me to
reporting access
not all families have access to a
reporting
location of opportunity to give a dna
sample
this is because they have a
potential lack of knowledge of the
presence of forensic anthropologists
there's um obviously a disconnect
between
people who are migrating from mexico
central america and they're being
expected unreasonably
to have some knowledge that forensic
anthropologists
are present and able to aid in the
united states
in addition to that there is fear
and problems of trust with
governmental and institutional agencies
many of the people who are migrating
come from structurally vulnerable groups
they are marginalized oppressed and
fearful
so to reach out to a agency that they
feel
is akin to a oppressive structure
would be would be very problematic
and then there's just simple issues of
communication
so not all forensic anthropologists
speak spanish
have the ability to communicate in that
way and then
more pressingly not all migrants
speak standard spanish so even if there
is that level of communication
um and there's someone who's boots on
the ground who they can actually connect
with
they may not be able to communicate
and then there is the larger issue of
education how do we
disseminate our knowledge and our
ability to aid
in the places that need them to
populations that
are already fearful of that kind of
interaction
so there are many social and scientific
issues that we need to address
in tandem and many of these
impediments are directly related to the
systems of structural vulnerability
and the presence of institution and
physical violence that compel
these forced migrants to take up this
journey such factors will include
poverty mistrust of government fear of
law enforcement
gang brutality political violence and
ethnic persecution
so then in light of that list of factors
the greatest barrier to positive
identification are the lack of family
reporting of the missing
and the absence of reference dna for kin
matching
these impediments are exacerbated by the
often limited availability of
information
on the place of origin or the sending
region
of the unknown which can be critical for
seeking out
family members and for submitting case
reports with dna profile results
sg migrants as i said are found in
criminal databases
so as i've already said marginalization
begets marginalization
through that concept that forced
migrants do not disappear but they are
forcibly disappeared
these structural factors prevent knowing
about the unknown
in the absence of family data accessing
information
on origins by other means is therefore
critical
so we have to figure out where to send
this information
or who to start asking to go ask
around for family members but we can't
do that if we don't know
the geographic location where this
unknown individual originated
so then how can we improve case
identification success
while motivated by these increasing
number of unsuc successful
identifications of missing migrants
how can we address this barrier to
improve rates of positive identification
and repatriation of the border debt so
my response to this question is to
engage try hybrid ancestry estimates
so the proportions of
ancestry for each individual the
case recovery location so the gps
coordinates where that individual was
recovered along the border
and because these um the cases that i'm
working on to build these
this analysis or model is um are already
positively identified
then i have their place of origin or
their sending region already
and i'm using these three sets of
variables to develop
a biogeographic profile
which is a model that allows me to
predict
sending region to aid in the skin
matching
and to enable repatriation
and how is this possible so
genetic diversity in latin america is
very high
studies using genetic and skeletal data
alike have revealed
differences in ancestry for many of the
geospatially defined groups that are
distributed across latin america
so we can use this spatial organization
or structure in ancestry
estimates to reveal information on their
spending regions
we can also capitalize upon information
that we can get from those who are
successful at crossing the border
so we can understand the habits of the
living to shed greater light
on the context of the dead so
demographic research and migration
networks
have found distinctive transit pathways
whereby migrants of different origins
so with different state or city of birth
or residents are associated with
particular destinations
so you come from a particular place you
are more likely to cross the border
at a particular location the pathways
through mexico and the crossing points
along the u.s mexico border
are shared by experience so
if you have family who have successfully
crossed or friends they transmit that
information back to your hometown that
information then
informs the next um persons who
attempt the journey so it's a
perpetualization of these
same transit pathways that are clearly
linked by
point of origin and point of destination
and we can use these trends then to
predict the sending region
for the missing migrants
how did i develop this procedure
so i started out with 150 cases from the
pima county office of the medical
examiner in arizona
i applied model-based clustering
geospatial
analysis machine learning and
traditional statistical methods
to produce this biogeographic profile
and i'll explain how i've done that in
more detail
as we move along to this goal then the
relationships among ancestry composition
so that tri-hybrid
ancestry um breakdown the geographic
location of the remains
so those gps coordinates on the border
the sending region of the place of
origin of the individual
their sex and their case reporting date
were all investigated
and i took that information and built
models that predict the individual's
documented sending region as a micro
regional category
on the one hand and then remarkably it's
even possible to predict the gis
coordinates
for that sending region when those
coordinates are taken as the centroid
of the um area um
state typically from which they
originated so
how do we calculate
craniometric measures of ancestry um so
i'm sure you're familiar with ancestry
estimates being derived from genetic
data
here what i've done is i've rewritten
the mathematics for
the genetic which is categorical
trait analysis to a continuous trait
analysis
so that i produce very similar
results to the genetic data
using almost identical or highly
comparable
mathematical procedures how is this
possible through craniometrics
well measurements of the cranium or
craniometrics have been used as proxies
for genetic data
to study microevolutionary processes
trace patterns of variation
and reveal information on population
history
and individual biology all through
anthropology
for its history and this is because
craniometrics have low plasticity
with high to moderate heritabilities
proportions of ancestry then can be
calculated from cranium metrics
using model-based clustering
implemented with the methods of finite
mixture analysis
and what's exciting about this approach
is that it's an admixture approach
that's comparable to the methods that
are used in genetics
so if you're familiar with the software
admixture or structure
it's the same kind of philosophy and
it's preferable
i would argue to the traditional single
group hard classification methods that
are used
um ubiquitously in forensic anthropology
because
they don't allow us to get at the nuance
of the
geography so by producing these
proportions
we can identify signatures that
represent
geographic regions these geographic
regions need not be
labeled in the same way as a
geopolitical region so we can actually
map them onto real geographic
space and see how they vary and then
create our own
partitions or organization to those that
make
sense based on the
relationships that we're seeing in the
ancestry estimates and
in the gis coordinates
so how is how are these ancestry
estimates actually
produced each individual's ancestry is
reframed as a mixture of parental
contributors
and if it's tri-hybrid we presume that
latin american peoples are
have their ancestry made up by european
african and indigenous components
so we calculate the mixture of those
components for each individual
or we can think of them as the degree of
affinity
between groups as well so once you have
those three
components then you can look at how much
sharing
occurs between different populations
based on the similarity in their
ancestry signatures
and this differs fundamentally from a
single ancestry classification for
multiple reasons first that we start out
with the unknowns
individual and we have a reference
sample of individuals as well
but we strip all of those individuals
from
there we strip away from those
individuals their identifiers
so no sex no population no information
on them whatsoever
we just use their data we subject it to
the model based clustering
and we get a probabilistic allocation so
we can see
how individuals share between all of the
clusters
and each one of those clusters adds up
to one so
sorry of the combination of the clusters
add up to one each one of the clusters
contributes
in some proportion of that one
or 100 percent so individuals vary
in each of those three ancestry
proportions which then serves as
providing a signature
for the individual and then when
aggregated in terms of a population
or a region or however you want to
partition it you get a mean signature
that then allows you for tests of
differences etc
a single ancestry classification starts
out with
predefined groups so presumably
geographically defined populations for
which you have
information you have your unknown
individual
and your unknown individual is allocated
into one of those groups
even though that individual may not
actually be a member of
one of those groups if their true
membership is not represented in the
reference samples
similarly it doesn't address issues of
admixture
which um in current
uh modern times is a really gene
admixture is gene flow
so it's a it's an important factor to
build into our models
so what do i find then after i've done
this analysis where i've looked at the
correspondence between ancestry
proportions
their place of origin their place
of recovery and they these other factors
of sex
and um and cashier well i found most
predominantly that ancestry is
structured by geography
geographic signatures are revealed in
the ancestry proportions as
i had hoped these patterns can be used
to determine than the likely sending
region
so if we see in the um
in the map of mexico we can see that
there is a gradation
or a climb in the degree of european to
indigenous ancestry
and that plays out well when we actually
map these signatures in terms of the
different regions of mexico
so the southeastern part of mexico has
indeed
individuals with the with the signature
whose largest proportion is um
indigenous ancestry
whereas northern mexico the individuals
have
their highest proportion of european
ancestry
and then we can map out how everyone in
between those
two points fall similarly we can
produce the same kind of analysis for
countries
other than mexico so we can look at this
is
um the second part you'll see a series
of countries
and the same tri-hybrid ancestry
proportions that create
a signature that represents guatemala or
a signature that represents
puerto rico and instead of then lumping
all cases as hispanic as is
a tendency in forensic anthropology we
are now
able to get at these individual
populational trends
that allow us to link population with
geography
i also found that the there are
significant spatial relationships
so if we map the cases um
by their region of origin and their
ancestry
along the border um their place of
recovery along the border
it's remarkable to see that the
regions in mexico cluster
in particular places along the border as
i had hoped as well
so recall when i mentioned that we can
learn
about the patterns of the dead by
studying the
transit pathways and migration habits of
the living
this i think exemplifies that
a way of thinking so if you look at the
lower right hand corner map with the
big circles the circle in the center
represents all the migrants from
southern mexico
and then the circles to the right-hand
side
and left-hand side represent um
the traditional area of mexico
and northern mexico and then the central
area
um is falling as an overlap between
the south and the traditional area
so we can see that there are clear
patterns to
where the migrants are coming from and
where they're crossing
and then also we see that there are
patterns in their ancestry
in those um in the positions as well
and um this uh
spatial autocorrelation analysis is a
formal test for that
so it demonstrates that in their
ancestry patterns
there is more evidence of clustering
than if there if it was just at random
or by chance
and i think these two plots um
are perhaps the most uh clear and um
the most relevant so we see that
individuals
crossing at the border are
clustered based on their degree of
ancestry
so individuals with
high indigenous ancestry tend to be in
the
central part of the region along the
border
whereas european are on the periphery
and if you think back to that previous
slide with the circles
southern mexico was in the central
area of the border which of course
based on my other slide that showed that
gradation and ancestry
estimates southern mexico and high
indigenous ancestry
should be the pattern that we would like
to see and that's what's actually played
out in the maps
so can we actually take this information
then and build this into a model
that can be used for prediction of that
geographic region in mexico
so i attempted first logistic regression
it explained only 38
of the variation and misclassified 43 of
the cases
significant improvement was achieved
with
machine learning methods so a neural
network using 12 nodes two hidden layers
activated by the hyperbolic tangent
function
with that type of model we got a really
high prediction accuracy
with even with level note cross
validation if we use a holdout sample
however
validation as validation on the r-square
and prediction accuracy was only
slightly lower and still pretty
remarkable
what i think i find most exciting is the
use of discriminate function
analysis because it is well known among
anthropologists
and it's very simply implemented and it
doesn't have the same black boxing
qualities that say a neural network does
and i found that discriminate analysis
produced
really exciting results overall
misclassification
is low at less than 12 percent if we
attempt to classify the individuals into
their region
of mexico and the best
classification rate is for the north and
i will say that the classification rate
is best for the north because
most likely because i had also more
northern samples
if once i balanced out the samples
north and south were quite equivalent
so what is the advantages of going
through this more
complex um approach to
addressing ancestry and questions of
biogeographic profile estimation rather
than just traditionally
estimating ancestry and providing that
within a case report
well using this biogeographic profile
approach
it's possible to identify the hot spots
where
we may expect to find remains and
mobilize workers to search those areas
and target areas where death occurs more
frequently
um and these would be on the pathways
that are now underserved or no longer
served by support systems
so there is a advantage for actually
recovering remains
it also provides valuable lines of
evidence to direct case investigations
or to support partial identifications if
our sending region
isn't known and family members from
migrant communities are not
reached are too fearful to report
they're missing
and cannot provide comparative dna
samples
the identification potential drops
significantly for the future
so we need a way that if we don't have
family members
coming to us to report or going having
the opportunity to go some
to someone um an ngo a humanitarian aid
group in their
location to report a missing family
member
how can we transmit that information
back
we need to know where to send it to
the method that i've developed here at
least
provides us with the first step towards
accessing that
origin information or sending region for
the individual
using relatively little information
that wouldn't already be collected in a
traditional forensic anthropological
case analysis gps coordinates
are obtained craniometric measurements
are taken routinely as part of the
standard ancestry estimate
we always know when the case was
recovered
and we have information on sex and time
should those two variables actually
prove to be
more informative i should go back and
say that
those variables didn't add much to the
model so it was simpler to remove them
without without complicating the model
so i think we have great potential for
thinking outside of the traditional
methods but that bring
in aspects of those traditional methods
the cranial metrics gis mapping is not
unfamiliar to forensic anthropologists
and to just integrate them in a
different way that allows us to answer
some of the most pressing questions
that are creating the greatest
impediments to
positive identification
and with that i would just like to thank
dr bruce anderson
at pima county um bruce is i'm sure to
the forensic community well known
and has been a pioneer and a tireless
advocate for identifying missing
migrants
and rebecca vanderwaal who is um the
student who i collaborated with
on uci uiuc um
and i'd like to thank um labyrinths
again for the opportunity to speak with
you today